how did I find people I asked and I was
willing to have people say no real real
very few people said no to me my whole
journey and I think it was because the
way that I asked was I didn't ask I went
and said hey this is all the stuff I'm
good at and I would just prepare stuff
and I would do work ahead of time to
help them with their business and I
would just get on a call and be like
here's all the value I could possibly
deliver to you if it was anybody worth
anything because winners give back they
were like dude I was not expecting this
dude what can I do for you I'd be like
okay I really have this question do you
know how to do this thing and they're
like no but I know a guy and I'll put
you guys together